hola muy bienvenidos a la entrevista de
france 24 en esta oportunidad vamos a
abordar una problemática que preocupa no
solo ambientalistas sino también a gran
parte de la comunidad internacional
estamos hablando de la pesca ilegal a lo
largo del mundo y como ésta afecta a la
biodiversidad marítima y es por eso que
nos acompaña maximiliano bello él es
experto en políticas públicas e
internacionales de océano maximiliano
muchísimas gracias por su presencia en
france 24
en primer lugar bueno se ha catalogado
la pesca ilegal como la gran amenaza
global no debido a la gran afectación
que tiene sobre los océanos y la enorme
pérdida de biodiversidad es así
realmente o se ha transformado el
concepto bueno pues muchos mucho gusto
estar acá buenos días a todos por allá y
bueno es un tema que es realmente
crítico y viernes sabemos que el océano
ha sido la fuente de vida para el
planeta por lo tanto el cuidado del
océano es una cuestión clave
efectivamente hay un problema con la
pesca que sigue creciendo y que va a
seguir creciendo a medida que los
los recursos se van agotando sin embargo
hay que tener en cuenta yo siempre lo
digo que hoy día el gran problema
realmente proviene de la sobrepesca y
eso viene de la pesca legal también
estamos llevando ciertos recursos al
agotamiento la misma fao cierto que es
en el órgano de alguna forma rector de
las naciones unidas habla que el 30 por
ciento de la pesquería está agotada y el
60 por ciento está en plena explotación
que según muchos científicos en realidad
eso ya significa que también está sobre
pescado por lo tanto podríamos estar
hablando fácilmente de un 90 por ciento
de los stocks pesqueros que están sobre
pescados si a eso le sumas que tiene la
pesca ilegal que no está contabilizada
en el fondo y sabemos que
aproximadamente 1 de 5 son ilegales
bueno hay un problema grave sobre esto
le voy a preguntar también a cuál es la
situación de los pesqueros ilegales en
aguas internacionales y especialmente en
las aguas de américa latina' sabemos que
muchos son de nacionalidad china pero
que otros países se estaban viendo
involucrados hay muchísima pesca
internacional sobre todo en las agua
en alta mar que llamamos cierto y de la
alta mar tiene un problema gravísimo que
es que no tiene una nota
la estación tiene un más que todo clave
o claro cierto hay dos organizaciones en
el caso del pacífico' que están digamos
que depende de la nación unidas pero la
verdad es que la responsabilidad es
bastante vaga y por otro lado los
recursos los cuales se hacen cargo y la
verdad es que no los están tratando nada
bien entonces hay mucha pesca ilegal de
montones de naciones que además también
están altamente subsidiados que es el
mismo caso de china y ahí tenemos
incluso cierto la unión europea ha
tenido grandes problemas de pesca ilegal
también cierto en especies alrededor del
mundo y otros países y otros países que
como digo están subsidiando a estas
flotas
pero también hay muchísimas flotas tanto
incluso artesanales como también
industriales locales es decir de américa
latina que también están haciendo pesca
ilegal en muchos casos y ese es un tema
muy grave también porque es la suma del
todo no claro que sí además ahora sobre
legislación internacional no hace poco
ecuador denunció que pesqueros estaban
dando sus aguas cerca a islas y su
gobierno sugirió una suerte de
legislación que le faltaría de la norma
para ser acatada a los países están
comprometidos en esta lucha contra la
pesca ilegal considera usted yo creo que
falta bastante todavía para que los
países efectivamente den una lucha
conjunta particularmente a la vez que
legal y además tram también que los
países no den apoyo a este tipo de flota
que lo que luego genera también la pesca
ilegal cierto hoy día por ejemplo
sabemos que montones de esos buques
chinos apagaron sencillamente sus
receptores de gps es decir no sabemos
dónde están en una flota prácticamente
fantasma eso tiene que ser tratado
también en naciones unidas y hoy día hay
dos procesos que yo creo que son muy
claves particularmente respecto a la
pesca en alta mar uno que tiene que ver
en nacionalidad que se llama vivienne
yale university billón jurisdicción o
sea la diversidad que existe afuera en
alta mar y otro proceso que también el
de los subsidios hoy día tenemos que
atacar el tema los subsidios porque a
través de ese dinero finalmente se
genera un montón de esa sobrepesca
y también en un incentivo de la pesca
ilegal yo creo que esos son los temas
más claves pero también es un tema de
cómo podemos como región trabajar en
otras cosas conjuntamente maximiliano
bello muchísimas gracias por su
presencia en france 24 muchas gracias a
ustedes un abrazo a nuestra audiencia
invitamos como siempre a continuar
informando se en el resto de nuestra
programación y recuerden que pueden
volver a ver esta entrevista y muchas
otras en france24 punto com
y